welcome back to 8701
so now the theory about higgs boson is
quite interesting and we have seen
um that it's able to produce masses of
both on the fermions um but
you know as feynman said a theory is
only as good as the experiment
and so you know we have to actually find
higgs bosons and measure their
properties and see whether or not
their properties are consistent with the
standard model
and so the first question we have to ask
is how are exposures actually produced
and how they might decay so this little
video
is just talking about this in very
simple terms
so um we are able to produce higgs
bodons and proton proton machines of
potent
colliders because they are able to
bring collisions or produce collisions
which
allow to have energies of a mass scale
consistent with the exposure
we already know now that the higgs boson
has a mass of 125 gb
so the collisions have to have enough
energy to produce this particle
we're using protons to do this because
protons can be accelerated
easier than leptons for example those
energies
but protons themselves are as we have
seen
objects which consist of quarks and
gluons
so how do gluons now put you six protons
and this is shown in this female diagram
here
where you have two gluons from two
colliding protons
and they are able via this
loop diagram triangle diagram including
a top quark
top crop goes around here to cause an
excitation in the vacuum
which is the higgs boson they
coupled to the vacuum producing the
higgs boson
and then instantaneously the higgs boson
decays and it can do this in various
ways and we'll look at this on the next
slide
and in this example it decays we are a
similar triangle loop
into a w
right and then the w is electrically
charged and can radiate
a pair of photons so while
the gluons and the photons are massless
we are able to produce exposures via the
collisions of two clones and observe it
via decay into photons this is quite
spectacular
in more general ways there's not just
one mechanism to produce six protons but
there's various
and the leading ones are shown here we
have just looked at this
first one which is called gluon fusion
fusion channel so to clearance fuse
together to a higgs boson
there's this one here the second one
which is called vector boson fusion
bbf where we have the quarks
radiate two vector borons this is either
the z
border of the w boson and then those
coupled to the higgs field and produce
the higgs boson
we can also have associated production
where we have two quarks
we are again a zebo then or a w
both on radiating then with the both on
a w border
and generating a higgs and then
a very exciting one is the last one here
where the higgs boson
is produced in association with two top
quarks remember the top quark here has a
mass
of 175 gb the mass of the higgs boson is
125 gb
and so we have two of those so the scale
of this of this event is in the order of
500 ged
this plot here shows the production
cross section as function of center of
mass energy now the
large hydrogen collider the lhc operates
currently at 13 db
so the cross section we want to look at
are those so you see that the leading
cross section
which in the order of tenths of picobarn
is the one
where we have gluon fusion an order of
magnitude less is the one with vector
both
fusion and then we have associated
production
and then the last one is the one where
we have exposures produced in
association with top blocks
because the mass scale is much higher
the cross section for ttx is lower if
you increase the center
if you were to increase the center of
mass energy of the lhc you see this
rapid increase in cross sections just
because there is more phase space
available for this
for this production the coupling here
and the coupling here
is the same then the exposure and as i
said the case and we have already
discussed
expansion ratios or branching ratios in
general
and since the coupling is proportional
coupling of the
exposure into fermion is proportional to
the mass of the fermions you see
the dominant decay is the one into hex
to bb bar
and then you can find lower decays to
the taus
charm and to muons here you also have
the case into the vector bothans ww
and zz and so similar triangle
diagrams we have the case in the blue
glue and into two photons as well
so we have already measured the hex for
at 125 gev
and so those are the branching ratios as
predicted in the standard model